hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of Marlena masters I
believe that the fastest and most
effective way to grow a business is some
model the strategies of people who've
already done what you're trying to do so
today we're gonna look at how a young
boy who grew up with a single mother and
was contemplating suicide in his early
years turn his life around by starting
his own business and went on to become
worth over five hundred million dollars
today this is a story of celebrity chef
entrepreneur Wolfgang Puck and the top
three lessons you can learn from his
success Wolfgang Puck was born to a
hotel chef mother and a butcher father
the art and love of preparing food was
in his blood Huck's father abandoned his
mother just before his birth leaving
Maria as a single mother in 1956 she
remarried the coal miner Joseph puck
with an adopted Wolfgang making him
Wolfgang Puck this marriage will result
in two younger sisters and their little
brother for puck under the guidance of
his mother who'd been dabbling in the
professional culinary arts for some time
puck began cooking pastries he had made
up his mind and an early age that he
wanted to follow in his mother's
footsteps and become a professional chef
instead of following the traditional
route of first attending culinary school
Puck chose to instead train under an
apprenticeship from the age of 14 he was
sent on a train to southern Austria to
work in a hotel kitchen but did not find
success he had hoped for after stepping
out the cakes on a bakery floor he
recalls that everyone told me I'm good
for nothing
a few days later the head chef told puck
you better go home to your mother's she
can breastfeed you for another year
after pondering suicide puck chose
instead to apprentice at another hotel
it proved to be a wise decision
puck decided to move to the United
States in 1973 and worked in several
restaurants before finding a home at
mommy's own failing a Hollywood
restaurant there he would bring the
restaurant back to prominence and become
co-owner
in 1982 PUC launched his first cookbook
modern French cooking for the American
kitchen with the success that followed
and upon meeting his future wife and
business partner
Barbara Lazarov who would encourage him
to follow his dreams PUC got the
confidence he needed to finally realize
one of his lifelong goals PUC was going
to open his own restaurant with the
backing of some investors he opened
Spago and the rest is history by
sticking with his passion am I not
letting people get him down Wolfgang
Puck was able to go from someone
committing suicide to becoming one of
the most well-known celebrity
entrepreneurships in the world to help
you take the next step
here are three action items you can
learn from Wolfgang Puck action item
number one don't complicate things the
easier it is for someone to understand
what it is that you do the easier it's
gonna be for them to sign up as a
customer and tell their friends about
you keep things simple focus on the
highest value that you can bring your
clients and be the best in the world at
what you do
the longer takes prospects to understand
your message the harder it's going to be
to grow your business PUC has never been
one for pretensions despite being a
gourmet chef who caters to the who's who
of Hollywood
I'm Amy of America's other elite PUC has
refused to succumb to the glitz and the
airs of many of the other top chefs he's
kept his recipes simple and their
presentation equally so as restaurants
designs unfussy and his overall message
clear-cut don't make it complicated
indeed for over 25 years people have
kept coming back and telling their
friends it's a casual yet sophisticated
nature with which PUC approaches all of
his businesses that has endeared him to
the American public as well as his
culinary peers his priority has always
been on creating simple innovative and
tasty food and to share that with as
many people as possible everything
beyond the food is an afterthought
according to Puck I think people can
walk by and they see the menu it's not
intimidating and the food is interesting
if they get good food friendly service
in a nice environment people will come
back and tell their friends it is the
happy customer who makes the ambience of
the restaurant inviting and excited
so I always believe great food great
service and wonderful customers put into
the right space will make a successful
restaurant if you buy good food fresh
green beans you don't have to line them
up in a row or anything like that
just put them out on a nice-looking
plate a mixture of things they are
familiar with and new things to auction
item number two hire good people
you'll always be limited in your growth
until you start bringing on people to
help you you only have so much time with
the day surround yourself with people
who complement your weaknesses and who
you can trust
hire slowly after doing a lot of legwork
and fire quickly if it's not a good fit
the better people you hire the more your
company will grow it's a simple design
despite being the name behind the brand
as well as its main inspiration and
talent the road to success is not one
that puck has walked alone from his
early days before the first bog was even
launched puck had the foresight to
surround himself by only the most
qualified and only those who he knew he
could trust as the company continued to
grow at an astonishing rate puck would
replace his business partners and
management staff as necessary choosing a
place in control those who are most
qualified to be there and who had the
kind of experience that he desired he
always believed that you had the higher
talent to create a successful business
according to puck whether you have one
restaurant or 10 or 20 or more the most
important thing is to hire good people
when they need me I go if they don't
need me as much I don't go as much we're
much better organized and we have much
better management what we have that a
lot of other caterers don't is a lot of
talent and chefs I'm not saying that
nobody else has talented people but
nobody has as many as we have action
atom number three never give up as an
entrepreneur you're gonna face some dark
times you'll think about giving up I'm
gonna work for someone else don't lose
hope don't give up on your dream do
something every day that will move you
closer to your end goal and don't let
anything else get in your way eventually
you will know success
it would appear puck is always
successful but the path to success was
not as smooth that it might appear he
stumbled numerous times along the way
and often had to learn things the hard
way
but he never failed to pick himself up
and get right back to work it was in
this recovery process the puck often
learned some of the most important
business lessons that he would use later
on in his career the closures and losses
were not easy for puck especially in the
early days when he was first starting
out and each new venture was close to
life or death but with each failure came
a lesson according the puck each time
something went wrong each time you made
a mistake that was one less mistake that
he would ever make again in the future
weather was to do with budgeting issues
management promotions or the food itself
puck made use of every opportunity to
learn what he could in order to avoid
similar problems in the future
according to puck I learned more from
the one restaurant that didn't work than
from all the ones that were successes
only you can judge your life you have to
live up to your own expectations there
is no value with just one restaurant or
with one person the brand has to be
bigger than the person
so remember don't complicate things hire
good people and never give up to finish
up this video I wanted to share one of
my favorite true stories about Wolfgang
Puck and some of his best quotes
Wolfgang Puck has been seen many times
by customers but never in the light
Terry Dunham remembers well one evening
he entered one of pucks new restaurants
in Las Vegas the Californian Pizza
Kitchen at the MGM Grand Hotel as dalam
tells the story he walked in and sat
down only to see puck through the open
kitchen he was surprised to see him
there at all but what surprised him more
was puck came out and took his order
then proceeded to make the pizza he
ordered himself
Belem stated that he could see puck toss
the dough put the ingredients on the
pizza and then place it in the oven
according to dalam he thought maybe this
was a dream and said he smiled
each time he watched puck sampling each
one of the raw ingredients before he
placed them on delivers pizza here was a
man worth around 500 million dollars
when the host of restaurants around the
country is the most famous chef in the
world is the main caterer at the
Governor's Ball the Academy Awards for
the past 15 years but took the time to
make one person of Pizza delhomme States
Puck brought out the pizza and it was
the best he ever had
thank you for joining me for another
edition model and a masters if you liked
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below I'd
also love to hear what you have to think
if you own leave a comment under the
video and you will see you on the next
episode
you